did you meet prince before he was famous
too
i no he was famous when i i didn't meet
him
talk to him but i was at a at a club
with him one time he's he's
funny guy prince
[Music]
he was he was the shortest guy that ever
saw him with heels
that's cool i i i i
met prince one time i was with the i was
with this girl
you know she was my girlfriend and uh
and i i used to routinely perform tricks
for people when i met them you know if i
really wanted to impress them
so i said let me show you this great
trick i'm going to balance this drink on
my head and then i'm going to drink it
without
using my hands and i lay down on the
ground and pick the pick up the drink
off my head with my knees and put it
down pick it up with my teeth
and he turns to my girlfriend and he
says
does this impress you like in the most
like
in the most condescending like frankly
dickheaded way
wow and i was like man prince is a dick
right
so then fat fast forward all these years
right first fast forward all these years
we're on tour
and i'm promoting my show in a radio
station
and uh the radio dj just says he says oh
so
you ever made a celebrity that was a
real dick to you and i'm like yeah
prince was
totally a dick and i walk out of the the
the
[ __ ] radio station and we go to the
supermarket
and then we find out prince just died
like i was talking [ __ ] about him like
like the day he died yeah that's not
good
i know but but hey man i wasn't like out
to get anybody i was just telling the
story
[Laughter]
he was kind of like the chappelle
character where he's just like uh
you know pass the ball charlie murphy
you know just kind of yeah
for sure i'm sure it's fine plus you
can't make everybody happy if anybody
knows that it's me
thanks so much for watching this clip
and if you drink
coffee you need a mug shot mug
that's my first ever mug shot and this
mug is available on amazon
as well as at stevo.com so go ahead and
click the link in the description below
this is what you're gonna find and grab
yourself a mug shot mug
yeah dude yeah
dude